Ashley guys I'm dying what's up with  this ice bucket challenge the only ice I  wanna see poured over my head is the  rapper hashtag are we there yet  why hashtag game threads at Ryan  Seacrest it's my birthday took me 45  minutes to get to work today on the 101  thanks Obama  hashtag immigration hey everybody out  there got an improv show this weekend  hashtag please come out hashtag for  drink minimum hashtag I will be sad if  you don't come please come  dolphins go into a murderous rage when  they are sexually frustrated  that's too good say that again check it  out guys I just met Michael Cera I  apologize that was supposed to be a DM  follow me for a free iPad HTTP colon  forward slash forward slash w w JCPenney  calm slash slippers your nipple hardens  exactly seven seconds after it is  flicked I don't even know who you are  but I'm gonna make one of you do you  hate when they're serving you dinner and  the waiter keeps calling you bye  I'm sorry